oh
i wonder where the um
okay
okay
i saw that video of you playing oh yeah
um
okay
ugh
coming in
oh yeah
thanks
it's maxed out
um
for a while
is
okay
is
that i'm uh
good morning all
yesterday the country paused to
recognize their nation's veterans
and on behalf of the entire republican
conference i want to express our
heartfelt appreciation
to every veteran who served our country
their commitment to service and the love
of the country exemplifies the very
best of america they deserve leaders in
washington who will hold the line and do
their part in protecting our individual
liberties at home
that is why i could not be prouder of
the house republicans and those who are
joining us in the next congress
it will be the most diverse class we
have ever had
many have already dubbed this year the
year of the republican woman
and it couldn't be truer from that
statement
we will are opposed to have 29 house
republican women join our ranks
surpassing the previous record
every democrat incumbent who lost either
lost to a woman
minority or veteran republican meanwhile
democrats are set to have the slimmest
majority since world war ii
pundits doubted us polls were stacked
against
us i don't believe one person in this
room believed we'd win
one race the cook report said we'd lose
15 to 20.
the majority leader steny hoyer said
just days before the election
that we would lose that they would gain
15 seats
and republicans would lose them sherry
bustross the head of the d
triple c i guess for a few days longer
poised that they would be double digits
victories
nancy pelosi the speaker of the house
claimed that she was not only winning
the majority she was having two
elections
this november that it would be such a
large victory she would guarantee the
majority
for the next election as well
they were all wrong not one republican
incumbent
lost republicans won
from miami to new york to minnesota
to california
the only seat the democrats won was an
open seat
and then they claimed to have won a
redistricting in north carolina
where republicans didn't even run
i heard the speaker called a mandate it
was a mandate against
socialism it was a mandate against
defunding the police
it was a mandate against wasting a
majority
that the democrats have done for the
last congress while the democrats
praised socialism and advocated to
defund the police
our members made a commitment to america
that they would restore our way of life
rebuild our economy and renew the
american dream
we are eager and ready to show up to
work
unlike the democrats yesterday
chairperson
signed she signaled that the democrats
have infrastructure in place to ensure
democrats can continue to get paid
for not showing up to work
something americans across this country
don't have the privilege to do
millions of americans have already
returned to work and millions more want
to return
if they are willing to show up in person
so can we
it could be done in a safe manner to
minimize the risk for members for staff
employees and for you the press just as
we did with the proxy voting scheme
house republicans will stand up and
defend the constitution
even if it gets in the way of the
democrats boat vacations
and road trips to rocket launches
we believe congress is essential we
believe you just spent
some
millions of dollars saying you'll be the
voice
for all the you in your district you
should show up and be that voice
just like in may when i put myself and
tom cole
and rodney davis gave a plan to open up
the house safely
with testing which a speaker denied us
the ability to have rooms separated and
distance
so we could have hearings in a safe
manner even to this day the speaker has
no plan
of how to have the house safely open up
our success is already threatening
democrats instead of planning to work
with us they are already plotting ways
to silence the minority party's voice in
congress
as many you know they want to change the
rules to the motion to recommit
the mtr as many of you know it
it's the only way that a legislative
body allows a minority just to have
one amendment to a bill
it's the only way the minority party can
use the influence
to improve legislation and serve as
their constituents voice
in dc we won't let them silence us
this election cycle has made one thing
clear
the republican party is now the party of
the american worker
that is the actual mandate that we had
from the voters
we are going to fight them push back
against democrats radical policies
and we'll continue to put america first
with that let's open up for questions
yes sir with regard to the election
uh nancy pelosi has uh and speaker
schumer
leader schumer has said basically that
that
with all these with all these lawsuits
that all it's doing is just
jeopardizing the democracy of america
you've got a hand recount going in
georgia
every recount needs to be finished you
got challenges inside courts
every challenge needs to be heard
regardless of who you support
in this election the end of the day we
want america to be united
regardless of how this outcome is you
want to be able to trust the election
if there was something that was wrong in
this election we do not want to repeat
it for the future either
just as we watched in the race in 2000
it carried out more than 37 days because
there were court cases
they were hurt i think when you have
more than 150 million americans voting
let's make sure we get this right yes
ma'am
texas is a concern uh democrats had
really pinned hopes on their own about
10 seats i think
um can republicans now say that
texas is red going forward for
the next few cycles look i i think every
place
is going to be competitive in the future
this country is very divided we're
watching all these races but the
democrats said
they were going to flip texas the cook
report actually had it as a toss-up
i think at the end they believed they
were going to win all these open seats
they believe they were going to defeat
incumbents they didn't
not only in texas they did not defeat
one republican
incumbent who ran for reelection
in the open seats they only won one on
the large number of all the open seats
in texas no they didn't defeat one down
there and we
just like in every other state on this
win we're going to have some amazing
women
beth van dyne who's going to add to the
delegation of texas
and to the republican party yes
you mentioned all these women uh
republicans
now 29 coming in but how concerned are
you about the marjorie taylor green
the lauren boberts who have talked about
and supported q anon in the past
creating controv
creating controversy for your for your
conference you marjorie taylor walked
around
did breath of hand give you this
question no
like marching band she walked around
with the bible looking for
reps to leave at omar saying that they
needed to
swear on the bible and not the quran
like how do you
how are you going to deal with but our
party is very diverse
you mentioned two people who are going
to join our party and both of them have
denounced kuwait
so the only thing i would ask of you in
the press
these are new members give them an
opportunity before you claim what you
believe they have done
and what they will do i think it's fair
for all
yes do you feel that any of the legal
efforts or the recounts will change the
results in any single state
or overturn anything related to the
overall election
that focuses heavily on the house races
i thought when i looked i followed data
numbers i i thought early on that
arizona
based upon the number of votes that were
left out could switch back
uh to president trump don't know if
that's going to be the case i see things
narrow
let me give you an example i guess more
on a micro level because it's very
difficult
like i have in my own race in my county
we have two congressional seats
they tell me there's approximately a
hundred and fifty thousand
and sixteen votes left they use the
number 16 and it's approximate
but they can't tell me in which district
they are
i just watched a race in new jersey that
the ap called and probably called way
too soon
tom cain is coming back up because in
the manner of what we've had this
election is different than others okay
a lot of by vote mail some states have
done it before others have not
some mailed it to everybody so when they
counted some counted certain votes
coming in and it'd be disproportionate
democrats
more likely voted in the absentee
portion and republicans overwhelmingly
voted on election day
information they're going to recount by
hand in georgia
that's going to take some time that's a
close race we had close race in the last
presidential
let's let
let's let all mccarry out and yeah some
of them could switch
yes ma'am you added a record number of
women to the to the conference but
obviously still a fraction
of what democrats have in terms of
diversity didn't even give us that kid
go ahead i'm sorry what's your plan to
continue to increase diversity
exactly what the plan i told you
two years ago that i believe the
republican party
is much more diverse than what reflects
on the floor
and i think this election proved it i
think when you look at who ran
who represented the party and where they
represented it from
when you look at the results and the
outcome it's only in this room
would we get a new record for the number
of women more diverse
and it only makes us stronger that's
what makes america strong
we're reflective upon that think about
where we won
we want two seats in miami maria salazar
carlos amenes maria defeated
a congresswoman who was the former
secretary of the health and human
service
who called herself a pragmatic socialist
when i listen to the democratic caucus
on twitter they're all burning up we're
not socialists they literally claim to
be and they lost over it
we defeated a sitting chairman of a
committee
been here more than 30 years
the d triple c owned chair had to put a
million dollars
into her own race in the last week and
it was questioned on election night
whether she was going to win
one day you should at least let us have
what took place that night
it was an unbelievable night for
republicans in congress
something that we told you about two
years ago that we would be more diverse
exactly the way we look at it across the
party those people had to run
they put their name on the line not only
if you take us from two years ago
only 44 women won the primary this time
94.
more women ran as republicans in any
time in the history of the republican
party before the record was 143
225 ran this time so we're doing
fabulous and we're going to continue it
and what's going to happen
with the success of the women the
success of the diversity
it's going to empower others to see you
can do it i can do it too maybe i've
been quiet about my beliefs in this
party
but i know this party has a place for me
so they're going to join
yes sir i mean talk about a little bit
two-part question
what do you want on covid relief in the
coming month because presumably you'll
have
some say mcconnell says he wants a
targeted small package and carries where
you come out
and next congress you're going to have a
pretty powerful minority i'm curious how
you
think about that in 2009 when you were
in the minority
you guys didn't participate much with
obama you argue he didn't participate
with you
let's not have that conversation i'm
just curious about your orientation
going into next
congress if it finds the president which
seems
it seems obvious to most people the
first thing i want to have happen i want
politics to end on the kobe
now you know i've been in all the
discussions with the leaders i've never
watched one leader play politics more
than anything else than nancy pelosi
she played politics from the very first
time we did the cares act
you watched her delay it a week you
watched her and i've watched her time
and again inside the meetings
she had one mission and one mission only
she was willing to sacrifice her own
members remember what she said
prior to uh departure when they were
talking about covet and
problem solvers had had put a plan up
what'd she call the problem solvers
they're irrelevant
she knew she her own members were going
to lose but her whole focus
her tunnel vision was it didn't matter
what the issue is
but if i can make president trump weaker
for an election i'm going to do it
and what she did in that instance is she
sacrificed our economy
and people who were hurting the election
is now
over i think it was very clear that she
should end her politics about it
and we should be able to get into a room
we've got money sitting there
what did the republicans do we put on
the floor 37
times to be able to vote for money for
kobe for ppp
there is more than 137 billion dollars
sitting there
it's only the date why you can't keep
going out
she dispersed congress because she was
afraid i was going to do a motion to
recommit
she changed how we voted to the floor
our continuing resolution simply because
she was afraid people would have got
resources and help so the number one
thing that has to happen the only thing
that's standing in the way
in my view is speaker pelosi
yes yes and you know what we we have
more
information today we've got more than a
hundred billion dollars sitting there
for states
this is money that's already
appropriated
why is it being held up people need some
relief
and we can provide it that money the ppp
goes to small businesses
it doesn't go to the owners it goes to
the employees
it pays the rent it's every small city
we know
a person who
you see the numbers are different
it is the smallest democrat majority
since world war ii and from every
reporting i'm seeing
if i'm just reading twitter from their
conference chair to
congresswoman aoc it doesn't seem
they're getting along very well
they're fighting on the fundamental of
who they are
for what they champion and what they
lost over
and they have the exact same leadership
team that they lost last time with
i don't know in history has there ever
been a leadership team
to lose the majority twice if they elect
the same
we'll know for sure whether that will be
in
i appreciate history uh
james lankford and chuck grassley both
say that joe biden should have access to
classified three things
to prepare for the transition usually
to classify the challenges
only because i knew you were coming i
wanted to make sure what joe biden said
too
um you know i'm part of the gang of
eight i do trust our intel community
and i want to make sure i continue to
trust it joe biden said
in regards to this look access to
classified information is useful
but i'm not in a position to make any
decisions on those issues anyway
so as i said one president at a time
he will be president until january 20th
it would be nice to have it
but it's not critical i think i kind of
stand with joe biden
i'll trust the intel community he's not
president right now
don't know if he'll be president january
20th but whoever is will get the
information
thank you all very much look forward to
spending time with you